should be live here.
Hello folks.
We are
going to work on the research today.
All right, here's the plan. Um,
there are some things to figure out on
like what do we want to build for the
experiment tracking.
There is some organizational stuff for
how we handle data. There's some stuff
for cleaning up how plots are going to
load.
present data and then there's some stuff
on how we're going to queue up and run
uh different jobs.
So
the first thing I want to sort of figure
out is how we want to present the data
here, right?
Do I just use
I'm trying to think how we store all
this data, right? my in my mind, I kind
of want to be able to just keep dumping
experiments
into a folder somewhere so that like I
don't have to do one contiguous run,
right? I just have a bunch of files I
can dump into a folder.
Having it be one experiment equals one
file is not bad.
Hey, Weston. Yeah.
Yeah, I'm
a couple pointers on stuff now and
again.
Um,
That's kind of awkward if we have 10,000
experiments, isn't it?
Yeah, cuz the thing is right Like what's
going to go on a plot? Actually, let's
let's figure out maybe we'll figure this
out, right? Like what should go on a
plot here? Let me go grab my Google Doc
What are like the plots going to look
like?
plots
speed sensitivity
okay?
Pretty easy.
Can this be done across
Here
kind of like seed
using
glass.
It's a lot of experiments.
Like a lot a lot of experiments.
Okay. But this is like these are two
very simple things. I Let's see if I can
figure out
what about sweeps. Do I need to plot
sweeps in some way here?
So, we're going to say
assume
that we can actually make
assume that we can actually make protein do this. Well,
protein do this. Well,
raw burrito frontier.
Is there any other type of analysis that
I'm going to want? I think there is like
some MISK other analysis
like maybe stuff like gradient
noise.
Um
stuff like two, hyper correlation,
etc., etc.
Hello, Kang.
Came here from the space. Cool to see
you stream this. I'm a friend with Zoya
from Phillips Lab. I met him a couple of
times.
Welcome.
Yeah, I pretty much stream all of my
research and engineering.
It's fun because, you know, Puffer is a
big open- source project and uh it's
really a great way to get people into
the space as well because like people
will be building new environments and
like trying to figure stuff out getting
into RL and they'll come by and I can
fix things for them really quickly.
And it's fun for me as well most of the
time.
Are there other types of visualizations
I'm missing?
10 minutes got hands. What percent of
runs does this happen in? Um,
so Kinvert, it's going to depend on
hypers and stuff. Uh, that's just
unstable parameters is what that is. So
if you like increase total time steps or
whatever, it's just that the hypers are
pretty aggressive most likely.
It shouldn't take 10 minutes to train is
the thing.
It should be like solved before that.
I kind of like
I don't really like the idea of having
to do these full hyper runs and then
only getting the frontier out of it,
right?
But what else can we get?
We can't really get stable regions from
sweeps like that, right?
Oh, you know we can do stuff based on
the frontier, right?
Uh the algorithm that we have for
hyperparams is called protein. It's
based on my own research.
It uses a couple different Gaussian
processes as well as like this
pseudoggenetic thing. You can read about
it on X actually. It's on my articles
tab. It's a follow-up to imbuai's carbs
which is cost aware basian search.
it's kind of we have a big group of
experiments for each of these
doing. Yeah.
Well, sort of.
Actually, the thing that I figured out
is all these
we got rid of the main normal form of an
acquisition function
because at least from what I found like
the acquisition functions were so
the Gaussian process is only
directionally correct is the best way of
putting it. Like anything that's based
off of the variance of the estimate is
just complete garbage. Anything that's
like really dependent on the uh the
Gaussian process being like accurate is
bad as well. So protein kind of is it's
still using the Gaussian process but
it's less heavily reliant uh on it being
super high fidelity if that makes sense.
like they're basically some things where
you assume the GP can uh can model well
in previous algorithms and we relax a
lot of those assumptions
stream do you have some go to resources
is.
Yeah. So, actually, since we probably
have a few people from that stream, let
me just real quick give you the uh the
standard resources
on what I do and how I get people into
this space. It's all free.
So, all my stuff's at puffer.ai.
All the code is free. It's open source
here. This is the library um that I
developed for high performance
reinforcement learning. The code is
quite short for a lot of the key stuff.
um guard if you want to help me out for
free. And the Discord is here. We have a
ton of people in here helpful and answer
questions. I'm in here as well. And then
on my X account,
this is where most of the articles are
in addition to the docs on the main
page.
You can see that there's like some of my
own research on here. There's some more
highle stuff. But then these two guides
here, these are uh this is like a
comprehensive resource that I've put
together for new people. Uh this one is
pretty good even for relatively advanced
like AI programmer like AI and ML
people. Just there's like a lot of just
good insights on science and like
misleading things in science in here. Um
but then the key on RL, right? This is a
step-by-step guide on how to get into
RL, right? And it links you to other
stuff that I've written. It links you to
other stuff that other people have
written. And it like takes you through
the process of getting into the space by
building things.
It's really not super advanced though.
The thing we've had brand new
programmers uh be able to start building
stuff. Like it's going to take you a few
months to get bearings if you have no
programming experience at all obviously.
But if you have like any level of basic
programming experience, uh it's very
very realistic to start doing things in
this space within a few weeks. And if
you're actually like a competent
programmer with some low-level
experience, you can literally get into
RL like the start of it in a weekend and
have like a little environment doing
cool stuff.
Okay, I missed I missed the whatever.
Uh okay.
So I think here that like
literally couldn't code anything
all without AI. That's it's in in my
guide. I have suggestions on this as
well. Um, learning to program with like
AI writing big chunks of your code is a
very bad way to learn to program.
in general. Like programming is um
it's not easy, but it's also it's taught
in a way that makes it seem like it's a
lot harder than it is.
Yeah, exactly. You use LLM to teach you,
but really you only you use them for
like basic standard questions. Honestly,
if you get into like opinion pieces and
stuff, they just become sick of fantic.
You kind of just use them as like fancy
Google.
60F arm is almost complete. Oh, awesome.
That's cool.
Writing code.
Writing code ends up yes. being the
process of programming. If you go high
level, if you start thinking like, oh,
you know, like programming can be typing
stuff into the LM, you're just going to
miss you're going to miss the forest for
the uh well, you're going to miss the
trees for the forest. Actually, we flip
around the phrase.
I mean, look, I'm not going to argue
that point though, but if you read my
guide, I think you'll get a lot of good
information out of it.
Whether or not it's the only way to do
things, it's a demonstrabably very
effective way to do things.
The one thing I'm not sure here is if I
want to keep
do I want to keep the full
training curves for each sweep?
I don't think I do. Right. That's a lot
of data.
You here? Just ignore me. I mean, we
help new people out, right? As long as
they're like receptive to information. A
lot of new people have gotten into this
base. Like very little experience.
And I'm sort of just thinking through
this while I'm talking. Um,
I think I need to just like start doing
this and not worrying too much. I think
it's going to be
No, I still want to have this organized
like separately.
Can you explain how you're going to do
hyper sensitivity? That means
right? But Tim, we're just we're
basically just trying to figure out
stable regions, right? But like let's
say that you run a sweep and you get
your final hypers. Uh if you were to
take any individual hyperparameter and
move it a little bit, how like how
sensitive are the final hypers? Right?
And then like do those regions overlap
across environments?
Like it's probably going to be the case
that a lot of the hyperparameters
actually just really don't have that
much uh influence on performance at all
and have stable regions whereas other
hypers are very sharp and others have
like stable regions but those regions
are different per environment. We want
to understand all of that.
But yeah, we also didn't get did we get
scaling with this?
I guess two hyperorrelations kind of
give us scaling. Well, wait. Compute
data trade-off is scaling, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Compute data trade-off
will give us scaling.
finals.
Well, we do different things, right?
Like
Oh, I mean I guess if you mean if
they're being like if the hypers are
being annealed then um the annealing
itself is still parameterized by a start
and a stop point, right? And usually the
stop is zero anyways.
That's That's not a big problem.
What platform and software you using to
stream this? Um, OBS. And then I'm using
reream to rebroadcast across uh X,
YouTube, and Twitch.
What is still bothering me? There's
something here that's like still
bothering me.
Oh, right. That I still don't have like
a cool way to like a nice way to store
these. So like if I do
if I do like frontier slash speed hyper
uh sweep
and then the sweep is the important one,
right?
Oh, you know why? I see why. Cuz it's
you want to do hyper pram sensitivity
across the frontier.
Yeah. So, what's that look like?
final space this.
Yes, Tim, it's possible that because of
the other hypers that a specific one is
sensitive. We're actually going to
explicitly model that though. Like
that's one of the things we want to
discover. And my my expectation is that
like the data efficient runs that use
really small batches and stuff, the
hypers are going to be more sensitive
there. I guess.
Yeah, I think I know how we're going to
do this.
Well, for synthetic benchmark, this is
not a synthetic benchmark, a real
benchmark.
Okay. Okay. So, now that I know this,
this changes things slightly, I suppose.
Yeah, BR
data viz is going. Um,
Now I have to figure out how to
structure it like this.
I mean, I can technically do a
regression fit actually on this, but I
think it's way better to do explicit
fit.
Now, the thing is that this is super
annoying because like
we'd like to be able to just keep
running this sweep.
an air hockey. Oh, fun. I don't know
what you're doing with VR and that, but
Yeah. So, the thing that I'm having
difficulty with, let me sort of draw
this for people.
here there are a couple different types
of plots I want to do. So, this is going
to be like
compute
And then for different environments,
right, we're going to get like parto
frontiers.
It should look something like this.
Like this.
Now, this is like the type of thing that
we want to see is that we get different
environments have these different
frontiers.
Um but then what we want to do is we
want to take like the data points on
these frontiers
Now we take this right we put this on
this side. So you got like all these
different compute points and what we're
going to want to do is have like for
different values of the hyperparameter.
We're going to expect the hyper to like
shift a little bit, right?
where maybe this hyperparameter has to
be changed linearly with compute.
But then the sensitivity, right, it
could look like this,
right? Where it's like more sensitive or
actually it should be the other way
around, right? Because it's not a
variance. Yeah, it should be like this
where it's like a super sensitive thing
at low compute. And then this would
basically tell us hey look this hyper
generally changes linearly with compute
but it's a lot more sensitive at small
scale than at large scale something like
this right and we can do this with
compute or we can do this with data and
we might get a different
Yeah, it's a lot of plotting, right?
That's why I'm doing all this custom
stuff because it's going to be a lot of
plots, right? Because if you think about
it, right? So, let's say this is we have
25 environments.
Um, actually, let's even see if we can
do this because this is kind of like a
huge amount, right?
So like let's say we have 25
environments.
Uh we're going to run 10 hyperparameters
with five each.
So for a single hyperparameter
But, you know, this is a number of
experiments we could actually run.
It's going to be a lot, but it's like
kind of in the range of what I expected
is tens of thousands.
But then we have to also figure out how
to convey this information in a way
that's like clean.
The thing that's annoying about this,
right, is that I have to run. So these
plots actually are not that bad. This is
just fixing sweeps, right? Like if we
get we can make sweeps produce us all
this data and then I just have to save
this
number of hours.
How's data measured? Number of hours
pass. It's um data is typically measured
in steps.
So for simple environments,
um, we're usually looking at anywhere
from like a million up to a 100red
billion steps. It's a pretty wide range.
Most of the experiments for this project
are going to fall in the realm of
uh between one and 500 million though
with some larger ones.
Yeah, our biggest experiments are like
650 billion steps. The biggest
experiment I've run is it's played
12,000 years worth of games.
Well, I think this this data here is
actually not that bad, right? This data
is just like
one folder per environment.
And in each folder, you have uh you have
a file for each experiment.
And then I just load up all the files
and I sort through the data and compute
PTO curves.
And then this one is going to be like
environment
Actually just environment hyperparameter
and then a bunch of experiments, right?
I think we have an understanding of
this.
Yeah. So, this needs to be a custom
logger,
I think we're going to be we're going to
be able to be good for the rest of the
day on like just chilling and working on
this.
Hey Jess,
we figured out uh what we're going to do
and how we're going to collect and store
data and now I got to implement
Which is uh it's a lot of stuff we have
to store.
So we're going to store the sweep data
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to compute the PTO frontier from
the sweep data and we're going to run
ablations on that data
uh that are going to give us
hyperparameter sensitivities at each of
those. But I'm thinking that even just
from the initial sweep data, we can do a
lot. So, I'm going to set that up first,
and we should be able to get like
something decently pretty quick because
uh I'm going to
I'm going to integrate like the fast
pong sweep stuff and we're probably
going to put this on the 6GPU box.
I think that's what I'm going to start
with.
I really should just get my editor set
up working on that 6GPU box.
Houston with research coding develop
more prod software. Any advice? Yeah. Um
don't like if you like production or
like big company software style is just
horrible software.
Like honestly, take a look at like
take a look at like really tight uh
smaller scale projects that like do
midscale things with very small amounts
of code.
Like all like the enterprise best
practices is just like how to absolutely
have no no ability to do anything as an
individual and to like very slowly be an
effective cog in a much larger machine.
Too much cursor versus too little. Very
simple. Any cursor is too much cursor.
There you go.
[Music]
It's actually one of the things in my uh
in my programming recommendations guide
is don't use cursor.
more ambitious projects. Well, if you
want to do more ambitious projects,
right, it's instead of trying to get
higher level and using more tools,
right, go lower level. Like go the
opposite of the direction you're tempted
to go. Instead of like, you know, more
LMS, more packages, more tools, more
dependencies. like strip all that stuff
away and go lowlevel. And what always
happens every every single time is when
you want to solve something like the
existing solution is 100 times more
complicated than it needs to be.
So if you get really really good at just
seeing the simplest possible way of
solving a a medium-sized or hard like
relatively hard problem, you end up with
something that you can actually do
case study for these projects. I mean
check puffer liib, right? cursor
purely for aesthetics.
We might have a different sense of
aesthetics.
Why don't I merge? Can I merge this into
the other thing?
Yeah. See, I almost don't want to copy.
I don't want to do this merge.
I know what I want to do instead. I'm
going to do it manually. It's going to
take me longer, but we're going to it's
going to save time in the long run
because I'm not going to have stupid
things happening
cuz this was like just a researchy test
branch and I didn't like take this one
super formally. Okay.
Thank you. I stream most of my devs. So,
looking to learn stuff on RL. I will be
around.
Okay. So, this is most of what we wanted
here, right?
So, what I'm trying to do right now,
right, is I'm just trying to re uh
retrofit this so that I can log all of
this new data in the form that I need
it. And then we're going to be able to
start doing cool visuals
30 small M's.
Uh, end review would take a while box.
And I'm happy to do reviews. I am sort
of in the middle of this logging stuff.
Let me take you just a quick peek at
them, though.
I will be happy to review those when I
get a chance.
Oh, holy. Wait, wait, wait. Which which
of these are yours?
I was literally just thinking
about wanting this today.
and Overcook. Yeah, look at that. Two
new environments that I've wanted. Good
job,
these folks. Holy,
I love open source.
Can I just merge these? It depends how
much of a review you want. If you want
me to do a full review, um, I can't do
that right now while I'm working on this
stuff. If you just want a quick merge, I
can do that, I think.
Well, I will I'll what I can do for you
is I can merge them now and I'll play
with them later. Just make sure that
they're decent.
We are starting to get this blowup
effect where it's like
The amount of boiler plate is kind of
obnoxious for when M's are really tiny,
right?
Like realistically,
this is a PR with an end that has
I don't know like a 100 lines of logic
maybe and then it's 300 lines of code
per M. So, we got to I got to figure out
a way to improve that. But that's not on
you. That's on me.
really have to solve. Well, if you make
it long enough, obviously it
Okay. So, it is a flat log, right?
This looks flat to me.
Oh, I'm doing a lot of science side
stuff, box, and we're doing we're going
to do like 25,000 experiments worth of
uh understanding how to make RL sane and
consistent.
You think it's worth putting curriculum
in ends?
uh basic randomization is absolutely
100% worth it for a lot of M's. Fancy
curriculum schemes
can be, but just note that there is
implicitly a pretty strong baseline
curriculum learning uh in puffer
training by default that applies to all
environments. So,
it's not as easy to get stuff out of it
as you would normally expect.
Let me figure out how we're going to do
this.
I'd probably just randomize the arm so
it's like, you know, different proximity
to the goal.
That's probably better.
cuz all these checkpoints are going to
be obnoxious, right?
We don't even need these.
Do I split it?
without in what good shape I am now.
Not unless Calvin Klein's paying Okay.
Maybe by next time you're here, you'll
learn some manners.
quite all right in that department.
Thank you.
That'd be funny. It's Well, I guess it's
not an uncommon name,
though. Not many people go by Joseph.
I think we're going to have to call your
psychiatrist, mate.
right. I think we can get this to work
from here. Yeah.
Hey, look at that.
Ain't that nice?
Hey, why don't you just sit down and
like pay attention to some of this and
learn something instead of just trolling
me?
There's quite a bit of cool work going
on if you look close enough.
Okay. So,
up time right
I see. So, this is going to be a
problem.
It's going to be an issue.
Oh, is the mic too quiet? Yeah. Hang on.
Why? Nobody do that
here. That should be a little better.
Moved it up a few decibb.
So the issue I think that I have here
right
this uptime is going to get computed
wrong
because it's going to compute the final
evaluation.
Okay. So, this is slightly
slightly awkward, right?
The the thing is the estimation code is
giving you the it's including the
evaluation at the end which is a
problem.
That's a big problem.
It's actually being done, I think,
correctly in the sweeps though, right?
Cuz like when I do this training, what I
do, if I recall,
Oh, I thought I had done. That's weird.
That was bad then.
I can just do cost.
I can definitely hack it.
Training is very fast in chess, but once
we get to zero time, it's super slow.
Oh, Jess, that's just the final
evaluation.
It's not that it's slow, it's just it's
the final like it's doing additional
evals.
I see. Yeah. So, the thing is I have to
restructure the way the logger works for
that, right?
I hear what you mean. Yeah, you're
totally right. I just I need to make I
need to figure out some ways to make
some changes.
We'll do some UX and like stuff on the
next version for sure.
But like I guess in my mind like puffer
4 can't just be some perf improvements
in UX. We have to have a bit more than
that. So, I'm trying to do the hard bit
First,
Yeah, I hear you. But I I really want to
do a full version.
way we version needs to be improved.
Yeah, I just try to make it a big
change. Hey Javier,
I try to deliver like you know
groundbreaking new changes with each
version.
You just simulate the universe. Don't
tempt me.
There we have our sweep points.
That's pretty cool. And just literally
picked those up from the sweep that's
live now. Like this sweep is just
running and dumping more files in. And
we literally just get to like, you know,
And why is the stupid bar not like
just
um
like literally this probably has a few
more data points, right?
Um, well, this is not the point is not
to replace Neptune.
Like, we're doing something way bigger
than just like making a Neptune
replacement for this.
The point is that this is going to let
us do like new types of analysis that
we're not going to be able to do with a
standard dashboard.
Yeah, I'm trying to make it custom um
heat map color. Hang on.
Well, we have to obviously fix this
thing, but
this is the graph.
Use the restroom real quick and we'll
keep on this.
So weird how this thing works. Right
back.
I've been playing some League lately. I
am so incredibly bad at that game, it's
not even funny.
The thing I'm stuck on in that game at
the moment is
I think I could get out of bronze if I
could just play my main champ every
game, but it gets banned like half the
time. So, it's like it's really
obnoxious when you end up spending half
your time not on your main.
favorite energy drink. I had enough in
college for a lifetime.
I was on like four uh four monsters a
day through most of undergrad.
What is this?
Wait,
am I doing this right? So,
Yeah. Yeah, this is backwards, right?
because I want to have
Hello. Welcome.
That's a heck of a username.
new talk toxine keeping your stream on
now all day. Oh, welcome. I pretty much
just stream all my research. At the
moment we are doing um
we're setting up some like large scale
analysis for
hyperparameter sensitivity uh cost data
trade-off and scaling laws and other
stuff.
sounds like you're recreating Google
internally.
Not really. It's mainly um
like reinforcement learning is going to
be so so much better than it is now.
We've already seen improvements in what
I've been doing in the past year and
uh it needs to scale like we need to
understand better how what we're doing
works like on a fundamental level cuz
right now we have like it's kind of
black magic. It's just automated black
magic. It needs to be less so black
magic if that makes sense.
Okay. So this is kind of nice, right? So
we have
cost
It's not a total black box. It's just
the fact that like it's more so the fact
that we don't understand
uh if I want to use less data for
instance, how should I set up my
training to use less data with more
compute? Um, how do I know whether I
have stable hyperparameters? What things
I need to test and not?
Yeah. So, this is actually
this is a super useful thing for RL. I
was talking with some people about this
recently. You actually wouldn't want it
to be part of the render code uh
necessarily. But yeah, this is a super
super useful thing with RL.
You direct me for lib OS. Yeah,
I mean I'm the main like the creator of
the library at least originally. We have
a lot of open source stuff now, but I'm
working on just like a branch of the
main one.
That's silicon. Uh, if you're I think it
skipped that question, right? Yeah. So,
sometimes X drops messages. If you don't
see your message up here, then I haven't
seen it
for the search algorithm. Um, FBR look
up Go Explore.
Jeff Cloon's Go Explore work.
That's the type of thing you would do
with this more than search.
You could technically do search as well,
but I think like go explore type uh type
stuff is more exciting to me.
Cuz if you're going to assume a state
setable sim anyways, you may as well do
this.
Yeah.
Yes, you can do MPS. MPS is not anywhere
near as fast as CUDA, but like Puffer is
so fast that for the simpler M, you can
still get like a couple hundred thousand
steps per second training. Anyways,
so Go Explore is basically just like you
train agents starting from specific
states, but the agents themselves don't
use search.
It's just like a really powerful version
of curriculum.
[Music]
You can try it. I don't actually know
how fast that will be. You're not going
to get anywhere near like a high-end
Nvidia GPU, though. I can tell you that
for sure.
Like the Nvidia GPUs are just way way
way faster.
Repeat contributors do get access to our
hardware though.
We typically train stuff on like 4090s
or 5090s,
which you can also just rent those
online for like 25 cents an hour.
Now, you don't need a 6,000.
4090 is good enough.
Yeah, I try to put some of the money
back into the uh well, I mean,
ultimately all the money goes back into
the project, but some of it goes to like
community hardware and
playing with Majoko. Uh he's not running
this on a Moko, right? He's got his own
custom sim now.
The joke is super slow. Like really
really slow.
Yeah, absolutely. A big part of what we
do is with custom simulation. Like here,
if you just check the website,
the vast majority of these are written
by contributors. They run right in your
browser. You can see the RL agent
playing the game. This is like not me
playing, right? That's the RL agent.
Stuff like this. We got this racing in.
We've got multi- aent snake.
Like all the each one of these is an
agent. Got like more complicated things
in here as well.
When are you going to release the
finance end? I just haven't had a chance
to do it. Like, I can probably do it
whenever.
It's just uh it's in partnership with a
client. So, we want to make sure that
everything is all good with them on our
like next deliverable before we do that.
I wouldn't expect much though. It's like
a really basic trading in
like really really basic.
was kind of just like one of the
prototypes we did.
What is that? Is that the Are those like
the discrete connected ones?
Oh, yeah. Yeah, those. Yeah. Um I have
no idea, frankly, how those do. I have
always just found it the easiest to have
a desktop
like I don't know I have several
desktops right
you released well I mean you kind of
they see the open source stuff and
they're kind of they're looking for
people from the puffer community do some
engineering for them so um they thought
hey maybe if we release some of this
stuff we'll be able to see if there are
any good people that would be interested
in
and bringing them on for this
3060.
Yeah, I don't really know much about
like there are tons of things you can
find on budget
budget builds. The main thing is you
want to have a decent number of cores
for RL. Like if you can get a 16 core
chip, ideally a 16 core AMD chip is
really nice to have,
but then most of it's going to come down
to the GPU.
Shaders are fun. We have um we do a
little bit of shaders just for our
visuals more than anything, right?
Like the terrain for this is all put
together with a big shader. Come on.
Oops. I forgot. I don't know why I broke
tab on this. But um
yeah, the the terrain on this thing,
this sim here is all a big shader mini.
There's some other stuff in here as
well, like
uh I will accept PRs that improve Perf
on Mac provided you don't like make a
mess of the Nvidia and like the rest of
the code, right?
As long as you're not like making the
coda messes in the part process of doing
that. Sure.
Like we try to keep our stuff really
really simple and compact as much as we
can
just because like RL is so complicated
that any bit of complexity you add is it
costs like 10 times the amount that it
normally does in the rest of software.
We typically go for like short and
simple over everything.
All right, there we are. So, look at
this. So, this is the
This is the curve, right? Like one, two,
three down to here.
Yeah. So, this is the start of this paro
curve. I think
we have all sorts of fun stuff. Uh there
are resources as well. If you check my
articles tab, there are like full
complete guides for people getting into
ML and people getting into like more
specifically reinforcement learning.
One for puffer. We already have Muan in
there. Muan is our default man.
What setup am I on? What you mean? the
uh my hardware.
Uh this is just SSH into a single GPU
box with a 5090 at the moment.
Oh yeah, MPS muon. If you just wait
until PyTorch ships their Muan
implementation, then we won't have to
deal with it, right? It'll just be in
PyTorch and it'll work on everything.
It's because we have a third party
library right now for Muan. That's why.
Oh, yeah. I can show you the hardware.
It's kind of fun.
So, the hardware setup that we have for
Puffer.
There's it.
Yeah. There you go. tougher training
facility.
We got like eight desktops in the
background. Eight or nine desktops and a
couple multiGPU servers.
That's the setup.
They have it now. Then I'll have to test
it.
Yeah, I mean I was doing work, you know,
I the first like RL work I did at a
company, I was doing like um internship
research at OpenAI when they were doing
all of their new RL stuff. Like Dota was
still in the works. Um follow-ups to
OpenAI Gym were under development as
well. And then everybody kind of stopped
doing it, right? and I've kept doing it
and now we have like next generation of
RL Infra.
Is that at MIT? No, that's at um
That's not at MIT. That's the puffer
facility.
Well, realistically, it's a warehouse on
my family's farm,
but it's nice and equipped.
Now, I don't have to pay for eaters
heaters, but I do have to pay for AC.
So, I'm looking forward to I'm probably
going back there in a few weeks.
At the moment, I'm doing a quick stint
in California, couple months over the
summer because all the business is out
here and uh so I've been doing a ton of
meetings.
I'll schedule a few more things.
Speaking of which,
my buddy replied
friend finally replied at like 11 a.m.
Apparently went out drinking all night.
Some research is a combo.
Yeah, you know,
I really just like peace and quiet.
I mostly just want to be able to like do
my work at like whatever pace I'm
currently feeling like doing it.
Um stay in shape. That's about it.
Oh, there is no way I would survive
vegan on uh everything I'm doing at the
moment.
I have an article coming up on this like
borderline psychotic block of training
I've been doing over the last uh five
weeks.
And pring my runs.
Haven't lost any strength either.
Yeah. I just don't know how you get
protein for muscle like
stuff.
I think it would also just drive me
crazy. I like meat too much.
I have mostly quit drinking minus some
special occasions, dates and the like.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't there isn't really any I
don't think there's any health reason to
not eat like chicken, right? like white
meat.
Is that a thing? I don't know if that's
a real thing or not.
I can guarantee you like depriving me of
meat will definitely make me quite
angry.
Not having a ton of sugar, not that
difficult. Not having meat, very
difficult.
Yes. Ah,
look. Can we just like cure diseases and
aging and stuff and then go back to
eating what the hell we want? That'd be
good.
Oh, I'm not I'm not like sourcing shitty
stuff. Don't worry on that.
I mean, this seems like it's done stuff,
right?
So, the thing with Brian Johnson, he's
he's really not if you think about it,
right?
Like you're not going to stop aging
because of lifestyle changes. You're
just not right.
Like that needs fundamental
technological advancements.
Like staying in shape is good. Trying to
eat like to be as healthy as possible is
good. Doing research to that end is
good. But like that's not gonna make you
live forever.
He is totally right though that we're
going to like we're going to look back
at this era and be like, "Wow, like
people aged and died." Like that's
that's going to look like prehistoric.
And I think more than anything, people
are going to look back on today like and
people just were okay with that and like
weren't really actively trying to do
anything because they thought it was
impossible. Like it's going to look back
as like the stupidest thing ever.
Like we're going to look back at this
like you know the electricity ads where
it's like a electricity is going to kill
everyone. It's so dangerous, right? To
have electrical wires. It's going to be
like one of those
Damn, his diet is pretty damn miserable
though, I will say.
We have these tradeoffs. We have these
points. I don't know why it's doing this
up here, but we have these
points.
You should probably compute PTO off of
this.
Health is not seen as a bad thing in the
USA. It's only seen as a bad thing in
like really idiotic parts of the USA.
Right. So what we should do here is we
should Do
Yeah. This is why like I ignore
I honestly ignore so much of the stuff
out there because it's like
honestly being a scientist more than
anything makes you distrustful of
science
like as an authority. It just it makes
you distrustful of it.
Like when it's like, "Oh yeah, such and
such studies shows that whatever." It's
like, "Well,
okay."
and give it maybe a six and 10 of that
being true or less.
Why is this so difficult again? Um,
have this function already, don't I?
Literally just let me just copy this
thing.
It's a pretty basic setup. Honestly,
I've had some form of VIM for like I
don't know last decade probably.
this is all it is. Literally two plugins
and then uh custom color scheme just in
there. That's it.
It's like a pretty minimal setup.
The only thing that I really like is
having um
Super Maven is nice because it's a
typing buff. It's just a really stupid
language model, right? But you see how
fast it is when I start typing. So it
just saves typing.
I will do 28.
What do you use to manage your file
tree?
my terminal.
and you're going to make a dependency
manager.
I'm probably not going to do like
general software tooling, honestly.
outside of stuff I'm doing for my like
specific research
work.
This is super weird, isn't it?
This This needs to not be here, I think.
honestly if you give me a massive check
I'm kind of just going to keep doing
what I'm doing now at like, you know,
with maybe hire a few people to do like
more stuff. But that's pretty much it.
It like really wouldn't change all that
much about what I do.
a decent trained agent PR.
Never mind about VR doesn't support it.
Yeah, VR is kind of like
I actually think VR is legit. Like it's
cool tech. It doesn't really have much
to do with AI though and it's very
premature.
walk around your end.
Yeah, but it's like it is cool, but it's
cool in a way that's completely
independent from the AI, right?
Like it's a cool viz demo and like VR is
fun.
It's honestly it's a form factor thing,
right? Look, I don't have my sunglasses
here, but once you get
I guess you can't really do it with VR,
but once you get actually good AR uh
into like a sunglass form factor or like
VR into a slightly more shaded sunglass
form factor,
uh then it'll be really freaking cool.
But like there's all sorts of stuff.
Like for instance, just having a screen
three inches away from your face for
hours at a time is not fun.
And it's like way worse as well than
just doing this like looking at your
phone all day. It's like way freaking
worse cuz it's literally like there's
nowhere else for all the light to go.
It's just straight in your eyes. H it's
awful.
It's really freaking cool though. It's
just it needs to be less.
Yeah, there needs to be a fewer steps
one here, right?
uh I don't know enough about the details
of what they're doing with that is there
any benefit to supervised learning for
task which can be called pure RL
uh it's the other way around right It's
the
It's you do RL when you can't do
supervised learning, right? Supervised
learning is easier and more powerful
than RL when you have data. RL is what
you use when you don't.
Way to think about it. What the heck is
wrong with That's
How does this make sense?
I guess it's cuz they're two axes,
right? So
that's a mess though, right? Because
then
Okay. So, how do we
figure out how to finagle this? Let me
use a restroom real quick and think
about this. I'll be back in a minute.
what's happening is just that the sweep
is not optimizing for uh the thing that
I would want to be looking for on this
graph. So this is actually the PTO
front. It's fine. It's just that the
sweep is not doing what we want, right?
Nature of RL changes the properties of
the net.
Well, yeah, right. If you don't have
behaviors in your supervised data,
you're probably not going to find them.
You could imagine having an expert set
of data for a game and doing a
supervised model and it's going to play
like a human would, but like it's not
going to find all the new strategies
that you could with RL.
Carl's pretty cold in that way.
Okay, I think the next thing is trying
to figure out this sweep
the sweep algorithm,
Let's actually here. Well, let's do
something here. Let's filter.
You still have like a ton of these runs,
right?
So you're actually here these are
slower,
right? You don't have any of these runs
that are fast kind of.
But then again, this could be many
things
go by steps.
Okay, we actually have like a million
step solve.
We have like a one million step solve.
Yeah, there's some extra evals, but we
get solved in a million steps.
Okay, but now it didn't do
This set of runs
I have faster solves, right? Look at
these.
With four million steps, you can solve
it
very fast.
The best one I think is
these two.
This was just trying to solve as fast as
it can.
But this is still not what we expect,
right?
I thought you were on the east coast for
some reason cuz I'm normally in Maryland
most of the year. I'll be back there
soon.
I'm finishing up some um inerson stuff
while I'm here and then I get to go back
there.
Today I'm working on
all sorts of hyperparameter sweep and
analysis and visualization stuff as part
of the new science effort been working
on.
Why don't we do
do Yes.
You work as an engineer. I work at what
you're seeing right here. I work on
making reinforcement learning fast and
sane.
Tougher as a company.
Reinforcement learning is very hard. All
my stuff is open source. But companies
that are doing reinforcement learning
internally and are having a tough time
of it can get priority support on Puffer
as well as fixedric contract work uh on
larger projects.
Is that published? Yes,
those are available on my Oops,
those are available on X
They've been my uh my best performing
articles. In fact,
they've gotten some nice endorsements as
well.
what Windows man there isn't one.
It's literally just two terminals.
Oh, that's why it is. Okay, I think I
understand.
I found that point.
soon as it runs
we'll be able to do uh
some plots.
Yeah, there we go. Now it actually every
time I reload the page, it refreshes all
our data.
I guess we don't know
get the scores off of these.
What about the um
Okay, the other thing I need to do is
the
While this is proceeding,
let's see if we can start on the other
stuff. First of all, let's commit this.
that I can write like incredibly
in-depth guides and articles on every
topic possible.
And then like there will still be teams
of 10 or 20 plus people on RL projects
doing everything completely
It seems like the algorithms are there.
No, we have lots of environments. Um,
the algorithms are not there. The
understanding is not there.
the techniques for
uh making simulators fast and in a way
that makes sense with RL still needs
work.
If you've worked in RL for any period of
time, it's like by far the hardest area
of AI
to do work in.
It's like obnoxious because you can't
just be an engineering type or like a
research type. You need both or you're
screwed.
The thing that's hard
If you see some of my guides, like
you'll see some of the material I put
out on stuff and like keep in mind
literally it's is a hundred times easier
to get into RL today than it was a year
ago because of Puffer. Like if you're
trying to get into RL with SP3 or
whatever, you're just screwed.
Hardware is not that bad at the very
least. The one nice thing is now that we
have Puffer, like
this is the biggest server I have. I
have two of these.
Okay.
Yeah. So, we got six 4090s in this box.
I've got two of these boxes.
And these puppies are going to run me
25,000 experiments over the next block
of research I do.
better to own it than rent. Um, you
can't really rent stable, consistent
stuff for these types of machines. So,
owning this is way better than renting
H00's.
And it's just as fast. If you had the
ability to consistently rent
uh this class of machine, then maybe.
But I bought them.
You know, I have the space and the
facility for them, right?
I am currently on one of these two big
boxes. I've just been doing a bunch of
work on like one of these other big ones
are the smaller ones over here. And we
have a whole bunch of extras.
You can see that there's capacity for
like another 30 boxes.
We have plenty of room for hardware.
Yeah, I can't wait to get back here. I
actually I've got like three more pieces
of of training equipment for myself
arriving as well. I get to train agents
and train myself.
Be good.
What's the electricity bill look like?
I mean, not bad if you think about it.
Like I think the biggest boxes
uh the like the big boxes can't do more
than
like 30 cents an hour.
And if I were to rent it, right, if I
were to rent like uh GPUs at a dollar a
piece, six bucks an hour,
it's like a tiny fraction
the rent what the rent price would be.
The the thing is that there's an
arbitrage, right? Because like the
server class chips are just ludicrously
ludicrously expensive if you don't need
VRAM.
This is actually going to be pretty
nice, right? If I have this as like my
working setup
and I can get this dashboard cleanly
be really good.
Cool. And now we can see how this goes,
right? Because I can do this one and
then I also have this one, right?
I have this one.
Can I have this one?
Dummy.
All
There you go.
And of course, all our nice GPUs are
sitting at absolutely terrible uh
utilization, but that's because it's
Fong
running a weird a really weird sweep.
What is this one do? Okay, it's armed
out a new job.
Yeah, it's taking like 5 seconds I think
to start new jobs.
So, we're going to have to figure out
how to reduce the uh the overhead
associated with this. But does it work
is the question.
Does work.
Look at this.
Actually, it does work.
That's super good.
I'll be right back and then we are going
to figure out how to get the overhead
down. Uh, and we'll see if we can get up
to the number of experiments we actually
need per minute to make this all work.
dinner while I watch.
Freaking starving. I got one week left
on the cut. Driving me nuts.
All right, so
I thought of like a simple thing we
could do for this, right?
I don't know if this is going to be good
enough to fully do it.
So many like little things that bug me
about This
Well, what I'm trying to figure out,
right, like there are all these little
things where I run these evaluations at
the end of the episode and technically
like you don't actually want to observe
the total time steps as the final eval
time step. They're like all these little
approximations and I don't know how much
any of them are going to be problems.
Need to fix things here and there.
I think that this fixes at least the
speed thing a little bit though, right?
Because here now I have a suggestion and
every time I consume that suggestion,
right, I get a new suggestion here.
So now uh it should be you shouldn't
actually ever be idling, I don't think.
Right.
The mic kept muting.
It sure as hell shouldn't be. It's a
good mic.
Um
the the
right this now instead of before where
it's like do a run and then when it's
ready to do the next run get a
suggestion. Now it should have it should
always have a suggestion queued up was
Twitter. Oh, okay.
That makes more sense.
All right. Well, at least look, this has
given us a lot of data points. So, it's
not like it doesn't work.
Now, let's see if this is faster.
So, I mean, we'll see after the first
set of runs whether this is what we want
or not.
I don't know if I want it to be Do I
really want it to be like multiple
suggestions at a time.
All right. So, it's totally the
suggestions, right? Just being super
slow,
right?
I don't see output here actually.
I think once we have this set up and
once we have the latency low, it
actually is going to get a lot faster to
do a lot of this research
because then like I can just start
setting this up on both of the boxes. is
and I can start queuing up like um
batches of 500 jobs per environment
quite quickly.
Something's going on here though that's
like wrong. Why
Oh, you know what it is? It is actually
doing it.
Okay, it's doing it and it's super fast.
Cool. So it is actually that's actually
confirmation
if this does what we want.
The idea here is that um
it should be 10x faster on the
suggestions.
What I'm trying to do here, right, it's
like it should be 10 suggestions at a
time.
And if it's 10 suggestions at a time, it
should be much close.
I didn't even read whatever the hell was
on Twitter there, man.
Yeah, it's just whatever the hell the
feed is though, right?
Like every once in a while I go through
and clean up the feed because it's like
half politics. Um, but like no matter
how much I do that to like try to get it
back to be research, it like it's a pain
in the ass. It like doesn't it like
consistently morphs itself back.
Okay, well this is way freaking better
now.
We're actually getting um proper speeds.
Hey, look at this. So, we actually have
all these different data points.
I mean, this is still going in a decent
clip, right?
The way that I have this configured, it
should be a max of 12 per minute.
There already a lot of runs, though.
Look at this.
So, this is well, we'll see if it's any
good, but this is um
this is fast sweeps, right?
This is now multiGPU sweeps with like
batch suggestions.
I don't really know if I want the
suggestions to be fully batched like
this, but
it does seem like it's doing stuff,
right?
No, I was just trying to This is It's
using six GPUs. It's running one job on
each GPU. So, it's batched. They're
trying to get really fast sweeps. I can
do all this research work way faster,
basically.
Like this is doing
roughly what we would hope.
So, the idea behind what I just did here
was there are two things. one, this down
sampling thing I'm doing for Pong
specifically is a little bad because you
actually have to keep running the game
for a while to know how good the uh
result is.
And then the other thing here is uh
just something related to the final
point estimate.
Well,
somebody just sent me literally like
hundreds of DMs that are like four words
each.
I don't freaking know.
Weird. All
right, though. Here we go. Right. So,
this is this is now doing all these
runs.
Should be better.
Suggestion should definitely come
faster.
So we will see basically whether this uh
makes any big difference.
At the very least though, now we have
we have something that should be able to
do this quite quickly.
11 million
1 million and 5.3 seconds. All right, so
now this thing is actually going to
start to get filled out.
We should expect some sort of curve.
Uh the curve that we're expecting should
actually be Yeah, it should be something
like this down though.
But like not this shape at all. Just
hasn't found the good runs yet.
So, this is exactly what I wanted. Right
now, we're getting I don't know like
probably 10 experiments a minute.
Yeah. So, we can get like 10 experiments
done a minute
and this should be able to be populated
quite quickly.
Now, it is a little bit of a problem
that this is
This is probably what's screwing it up,
right? Is that these are considered
parto.
Let me think about how I can do
something about that.
the problem with this, I think, is it's
trying to find like these are
technically bare
Yeah. Okay.
I see the problem now. I'm trying to
think how I can fix this.
actually. I thought protein is
specifically not supposed to do that.
These points are actually Purto though,
aren't they? Because
yeah, this is bad because
there's nothing that
we have good runs that are slightly
slower and we have good runs that take
more steps.
But these are technically paro even
though they suck.
Yeah. The fact that just the fastest run
is going to be a purto point is not
good, right? because then that means
and like you're going to be able to get
at like a whole bunch of different
speeds of runs that have approximately
the same number like some fewer some
more steps.
Okay, so that can add in a whole bunch
of bad PTO points and this stuff really
doesn't work when you have bad Purto
points, right?
It's just because these runs are super
fast is all right.
Yeah, look at these.
Seven.
Seven bad burrito points.
I mean, it's optimized, right? It's gone
in ahead and it's found the uh it's
found some like ludicrously fast
settings,
The problem is that these are getting
added to search centers. Yeah.
and let's just confirm real quick that
this does it well.
Very nice.
All right, let's see what this guy does.
There we go. This is already way better,
right?
It is somewhat concerning though that
like this is already a lot of points for
it to not be finding very much.
Well, I suppose it doesn't have down
sampling. There a bunch of restrictions.
Maybe it's fine.
Weird to me. We haven't really gotten
anything that really draws the full
curve yet. Maybe we were just not
sweeping correctly before.
better.
Yeah, we're we are getting Okay, so we
got the throughput that I was wanting,
right? We got the speeds.
Uh a little bit of patience perhaps
because
maybe it does take a little long
before
I mean, maybe it takes a few more runs
with this sort of a setup.
Max cost going up over time.
We'll have to deal with that separately,
I think.
Not a huge deal for now, though. That's
not like the thing that's causing us
problems
realistically.
Okay, this is kind of weird, right? That
it's like should have the other shape.
Why hasn't it found anything that solves
yet at this
this range?
shape is way
it's like not good for having run this
many experiments already.
I suppose there are more degrees of
freedom than before.
This sweep is going to be almost done
and not going to be amazing. I think
thing is not it's just not finding
particularly good experiments somehow.
Actually, it's found a few that are like
solve in a lot of time, but not much.
Oh, I guess you know what it is.
A lot of these runs are pushed up to the
top. Let's go.
I guess there is kind of an
encouragement for it to run a ton of
expensive experiments.
Put a lot of Purto points up there,
right?
Wait, make scale on max cost. It's
seconds.
What is this? This is
uh me messing with large scale
hyperparameter analysis and speaks
trying to get a uh a good tradeoff
between compute usage and data usage.
Little bit of uh trouble with some of
it.
We do have
it's done something. Eight.
Make yaxis scale.
What do you mean make yaxis scale?
I can't make like
it's a this is there are three different
quantities here, right? There's cost,
there's steps, and then there's
performance.
Doesn't fit on a 2D graph. That's why I
have the points colored the way they
are.
Do not need to know if the cost is above
30. It can't be above 30.
So, the way it works is if you spend
more than 30 seconds on an experiment
for something as simple as pong, it'll
just stop the experiments.
Oh, I see what you mean by make it
scale. It does scale, right?
It's not that those points are off the
screen. It's just that's where it's
capped.
Okay. Okay. Well, it's done sort of
something here.
That's too many experiments for take
that
lost as hell. How long it takes to run
an experiment
in seconds.
I guess there just end up being a lot
more Purto points, right?
Where on the graph indicates good
points.
Um,
so being anywhere on the graph is not
enough. It's a blue point that's as far
down and to the left as possible is
good.
You need to have high score and low cost
like low cost in either steps or in
seconds.
Yeah. I mean, this is a very early
graph, right? It's going to be kind of
jank. Obviously,
I'm mostly concerned with why this is
not sweeping in any sort of decent way.
I guess that's not entirely true, right?
It found some cool
It found some like two and three mill
step solves, I guess.
I'm trying to think what I can do from
here.
It's going to be way worse if I just do
random search, right?
There's something directionally with the
though.
one and two.
What? How is that relevant?
I might have the uh I might have the
math wrong. One second.
Yeah. So, the thing that you're
misunderstanding is this is a simple
enough problem that we should be able to
have something good by this time.
Like it shouldn't take it should not
take 500 experiments. 200 should be more
than enough. It should be actually be
able to do this in 100 if it's decent.
I think I'm starting to understand this.
Hang on.
So
Okay, so here's the thing, right?
We're defining cost only based on one
axis.
So actually a point if you have the same
score
any point to the left is parrito and any
point that's down is parrito.
like break try to do multi-dimensional
burrito
Maybe I just have it backwards.
I think I just have it backwards. It's
just dumb. I might just be dumb. Come
on.
Yeah, it is this. Okay, I had that other
thing wrong. So, we'll see if this does
anything. Now,
this could actually make a big
difference.
Yeah, this should
I had Purto set up wrong for multi uh
multi-dimensional data.
We'll see if this gives us rapidly uh
something useful.
But then wasn't there there was
something weird, wasn't there?
Like I remember Neptune.
it'll start to look a lot better if we
do it this way, right?
A little bit.
Where's uh our run over here?
Oh, you know what?
Wonder if we just logged cost wrong.
Yeah, I think I just probably made some
small
There must have just been some small
errors with how I was logging stuff. All
right. No, we're going to be able to fix
this 100%.
So hopefully now that we're doing this
reasonably.
Uh shouldn't be able to have data points
up here though.
Maybe this is all there was to it.
This is the shape that we want. We'll
see whether this actually cleans itself
up.
a decent shot. I can just leave this for
a 500 run over dinner, right?
Same thing with breakout.
There we are.
Getting somewhereish.
Quick question. Apart from being slow
and bad, is gymnasium docks good for
beginner?
Um, it doesn't explain anything really.
It's not like gymnasium is not a RL
learning library. It's literally just an
environment spec in like some default
environments
like yeah I would just follow my guide
right you just make a little game in
Rayb
I like my guide links you to good
materials that are not just my own as
well like if you want a starter library
you look at clean RL but the problem is
like you can read the clean RL code, but
you're not going to actually be able to
train stuff at a reasonable speed in it.
Right?
as easy if you just join the Discord
like there are tons of useful people in
there that help
self included
The RL is good
as it turns out.
Still not getting like great points
here.
Annoying.
It's got a lot of these pretty high cost
suggestions for some reason, right?
Why is it doing this?
They're like not good.
Is lower high cost. These are not good
samples.
I guess
the sampling is a little screwy, right?
I mean, I could just give it two
samples, but
There might have to be some kind of
fundamental changes.
See,
this one's at least running.
So I think what's going on here, right,
is I'm only telling it, hey, go find me
like a 20 million step sample or go find
me a 20 like a 20 second sample and then
it's going to push the other one up. I
think it's like basically the way that
the sampling is going. It's forcing it
to the bounds,
what to do with this.
It's tough when you have two different
costs.
I can't just do both,
right?
Yeah, if you just run a tuning, run it
like if you just if it's fast, you can
just run a sweep at 200
all the day.
Uh, that's not super fast. You can
overnight like one or 200 experiments.
Oh, okay. Okay, I forget your machine is
uh then your MV is probably fine. It's
just your machine.
Hello, Kevin. Why was I streaming?
I wasn't. I was just chatting on a
Twitter space
and uh he's been doing um he's been
doing a ton of like RL stuff with
Puffer. I've been like pointing him in
the right direction since he's new to
RL, right?
I'm trying to get all this sweep stuff
automated.
The idea behind this right
is to fill in the compute data frontier.
But it turns out that adding a dimension
to paro optimality optimization is um
it makes it hard. It turns out
must be missing something really. But
we'll see if this one does anything
good. Right.
This one should technically be able to
do something quite different.
I'm trying to think if there's another
way to formulate this that's simpler,
though.
Like it shouldn't be an either or kind
of a thing, right?
Kind of odd.
When four M's in the config, you're
bottlenecked by your brain. That'll do
it.
I am typically bottlenecked by having
any energy to do my work, at least in
the last couple of weeks with the cut.
I will be good as soon as I am able to
eat food again.
it's Saturday. I work going to dinner
pretty soon.
Even when I'm done cutting, I actually
just don't eat that much.
It's actually pretty hard to put on
weight.
I mean, we can do the math on this,
right? Like
here, this is how ridiculous this is.
So
five weeks
uh times 7 days.
Oh, actually here it should be 15
pounds.
3,000. Is it 3,000 calories a pound?
divided by this many days?
1500 calorie a day cut.
I don't know if this is doing anything
yet. We'll see.
All these like high cost runs are
screwy.
I've written a decent chunk of the
research blogs at the very least on this
stream.
to doing this.
Shouldn't have the cost be that high.
I wonder if I like massively
could I have massively messed up
I could have massively messed up, right?
That's honestly almost more believable.
figure out.
Think I totally messed this up, but
I'm just going to have to run this. And
I think I got to get dinner because I'm
not making progress on this as is.
Um,
that's okay. I will be back
on Monday. I'm going to keep running
some experiments on this over the
weekend as well,
but I'm gonna go get dinner because I'm
starving. I gotta go run. Uh, well, I
get to eat a bit more for dinner. It's
cuz I have But it's cuz I have to run
tomorrow.
Trying to think how long I want to do.
At least 10 miles.
Possibly a bit longer.
12 would be nice. We'll see what I do.
All right, though. Um, for folks
watching,
all my stuff is at puffer.ai.
If you'd like to help me out for
absolutely free, just start the
repository. It's literally it helps a
ton.
You want to get involved, join the
Discord. And other than that, follow me
on X for more RL content, including all
my articles.
Other than that, enjoy your weekend.